[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec joëlle mélin députée
européenne identité démocratie médecin
généraliste est également bon soir
joëlle mélin merci d'être avec nous
laurent alexandre hezez liste est
chirurgien est avec nous également
bonsoir laurent alexandre merci à tous
les deux d'être avec nous laurent
alexandre commence par vous puisque on
va regarder votre tweet en même temps
vous vous êtes fait vacciner ce matin
est manifestement vous fait campagne sur
les réseaux sociaux en faveur de la
vaccination vont chercher à convaincre
les sceptiques le vaccin est le seul
moyen de se débarrasser du virus selon
vous oui il n'y a pas d'autre solution
nous n'avons hélas aucun antiviral qui
fonctionne contre le virus ni ni les
interférons ni la chloroquine ni le rem
désir ni le petit navire ne fonctionne
donc la seule solution pour qu'on
retrouve une vie normale qu'on sauve nos
aînés qu'on évite les kovy de long c'est
de nous faire vacciner rapidement et
c'est pour ça que j'ai twitté ma propre
vaccination je me suis fait vacciner par
cette remarquable innovation quel vaccin
arn qui donne extraordinairement peu
d'effets secondaires et qui a une
efficacité formidable et je voulais un
site aimé follower les gens qui me
suivent à se faire vacciner le plus vite
possible
quand il y aura des doses vaccinales
mais vous savez bien que malheureusement
l'union européenne a commandé propos de
vaccins et nous n'allons vacciner qu'à
un rythme entre cinq et dix fois plus
faible que ce que fait par exemple
israël en ce moment il va être le
premier pays au monde à retrouver un
mode de vie normal puisqu'ils ont déjà
vacciner 65 % des gens de plus de 60 ans
et qu'ils auront fini la vaccination de
tous les adolescents de plus de 16 ans
et de tous les adultes entre mi mars et
fin mars
alors vous êtes d'accord va y revenir à
laurent alexandre parce que c'est
intéressant ce que vous nous dites pas
ce que c'est vrai qu'israël n'a pas de
payer totalement la même chose que que
l'europe sur ses vaccins mais était
effectivement servi davantage joëlle
mélin vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui
vient
d'être dit le vaccin c'est la seule
porte de sortie de ce virus sachant et
il ne faut pas les oublier qu'il ya
beaucoup de sceptiques dans ce pays
beaucoup de personnes qui pensent qu'il
n'y a pas assez de recul notamment sur
les études qui ont été faites au sujet
de ce vaccin
alors je vais bien entendu vous répondre
je m'étais donné une petite précision
par avance il se trouve qu'il ya
longtemps que je ne suis plus
généraliste mais que je suis par
ailleurs gériatre et que je suis un
ancien expert judiciaire en matière de
responsabilité médicale donc je suis
extrêmement attentive à ce qui se passe
pour répondre précisément à votre
question je pense que dans l'état actuel
des choses et compte tenu de l'urgence
dans laquelle nous sommes malheureux
quelque part malheureusement pour ceux
qui sont sceptiques
il n'y a que le vaccin et je trouve que
monsieur alexandre beaucoup de chance
parce que moi j'ai tenté de me faire
vacciner sur vannes et je vais devoir
attendre encore quelques semaines
ceci dit là où j'ai quand même une
remarque à faire c'est que malgré les
sommes tout à fait importantes qui ont
été mises sur la table pour la recherche
et je crois savoir d'ailleurs que
l'union européenne a débloqué des fonds
dès le 31 décembre 2019 par le biais de
la cellule prépare et du comité outbreak
nous n'avons à ce jour aucune étude tout
à fait satisfaisante qu'ils soient
sortis sur les alternatives aux vaccins
j'entends par là on sait qu'il ya des
vieux antibiotiques des vieux anti
inflammatoire qui pourrait marcher mais
nous n'avons aucune étude
et puis aucune étude en toutes celles
qui ont été lancées ont été arrêtés
avant même qu'on puisse prouver que la
chloroquine n'aurait pas marché
donc c'est un peu dommage qu'on n'ait
pas d'alternative pour ceux qui sont
sceptiques en ce qui me concerne je
pense que la vaccination telle qu'elle
nous est présentée encore satisfaisante
puisque nous avons affaire à la rn
messager qui est une nouvelle méthode
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas totalement un
bac 5 et une thérapie la personne
vaccinée peut transmettre encore la
maladie mais en fait tout ça ça nous
permettra sans doute d'avancer et je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour dire
qu'en france nous avons un retard tout à
fait conséquents mais pas que
sur la vaccination la fragmentation de
toutes les étapes qui ont été dissociées
au lieu d'être mises ensemble à savoir
tester d'abord à empêcher la circulation
pas du test puis l'évaluation et surtout
des quarantaines ils sont maintenant des
semaines et les isolements qui aurait
permis sérieusement de couper la chaîne
du neutre de contamination n'ont pas été
respectées quand on pour terminer la
vote sur votre question le fait de
passer à un confinement à 18 heures
c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas vu ce que
donnait le confinement à 20 heures voilà
on va te revenir jouer le mail un
restaurant lors des parents de ce vaccin
va revenir justement sur ces mesures de
restriction après illustration de ce que
vous venez nous dire est ce que le
docteur alexandre venait de nous dire
précédemment effectivement on n'est pas
vraiment en avance en france première
piqûre le 7 décembre dernier regarder
petit comparatif sur cet écran avec nos
voisins européens et même plus on a fait
un tableau au classement pourcentage de
population vaccinée et vous le voyez la
place de la france dernière colonne en
bas à droite on est clairement bon
dernier olivier vers ont été auditionnés
nuit aujourd'hui à l'assemblée pourtant
le ministre de la santé a balayé les
critiques sur la stratégie sanitaire
gouvernementale on les écoute avant de
vous faire réagir
nous ne l'avions pas vu une stratégie a
été défini par la haute autorité de
santé qui est je le rappelle une
autorité indépendante alors alexandre un
gouvernement qui vise les 400 milles
vacciner déficit la fin de la semaine un
million d'ici la fin du mois il faut
aller plus vite la prise de rendez vous
notamment pour les vaccins sur d'octo
lips est notamment l'un des outils qui
va permettre d'accélérer
oui oui je pense qu'il faut aller plus
vite il n'est pas normal qu'il y ait un
million plus d'un million de doses de
vaccins qu'ils soient dans les frigos
ces doses devrait déjà être dans les
bras des gens qui pourraient être
vaccinés comme gelée était ce ce matin
on sait que la protection devient bonne
à partir du 12e jour 11e ou 12e jour
après la première injection
il faut bien sûr faire les deux
injections mais on est déjà fortement
protégée au bout d'une semaine et demie
la première donc ça va sauver des vies
de vacciner vite on l'a dit on manque de
vaccination de vaccins on peut on peut
vacciner plus vite en vaccinant tout ce
qu'il ya dans les frigos
mais de toute façon ne pouvons pas avoir
une stratégie à l'anglais ou à
l'israélienne parce que nous allons
manquer de doses vaccinales
l'union européenne n'a pas pris les
options qu'elle avait pendant l'été elle
a laissé pourrir la situation
pendant pendant l'été et au moment où
netanyahu le premier ministre israélien
appelez personnellement vie cette fois
le président de pfizer pour avoir
davantage de doses en payant les doses
40% plus cher que le marché
eh bien nous ne faisions pas ça l'europe
a été négligente à emmanuel macron et la
présidente de la commission n'ont pas
appelé 17 fois le président des
laboratoires pfizer pour récupérer des
doses l'europe à chipoter sur le prix
des vaccins au lieu de surpayer les
vaccins comme certains pays l'ont fait
et on le paie au prix fort
on aurait mieux fait d'acheter vaccin 50
euros pièce
évitez le troisième rang confinement qui
est aujourd'hui quasiment inévitable au
moment où le variant britannique
malheureusement mais est loin d'être
majoritaire mais se développe très vite
il y a très probablement déjà des
milliers des milliers des milliers de
gens qui ont été en france contaminée
avec le variant britannique donc la
situation est en train d'être rattrapé
les lourdeurs bureaucratiques insensé
qui avait été mis en place au début pour
faire plaisir aux anti vaccins sont
progressivement
je me suis tapé personnellement 45 et
les quinze pages du guide de vaccination
dans les ehpad
je n'ai jamais vu une langue de bois dur
cratique aussi inutiles et aussi longue
45 pages pour expliquer comment on
vaccine des personnes âgées s'est démis
débile et dément et d'ailleurs le
président macro comme le rappelle le
point cette semaine a été abasourdi par
la connerie bureaucratique du guide de
vaccination dans les ehpad et je
conseille aux gens est intéressant la
politique de de lire les 45 pages de ce
guide complètement j'espère qu'ils ne
manqueront pas
joëlle mélin finalement cette lenteur
que nous décrit laurent alexandre ça
n'arrange peut-être plus d'un en france
puisque comme le docteur alexandre le
souligner de toute manière nous n'avons
pas assez de doses
la faute à l'europe on aurait dû
peut-être plus souple pays par pays de
façon à payer peut-être plus cher de
commander différemment mieux cibler les
commandes est ce que on le doit
justement la lourdeur de l'europe selon
vous oui absolument ce matin nous avions
encore une audition avec la directrice
de la dg santé et la direction générale
de la santé à la commission européenne
qui s'insurgeaient contre le fait que
les pays membres de l'europe puisse
envisager d'acheter des vaccins en
dehors des prêts achats groupés qui ont
été faits à la suite des contrats qui
ont été passés et ça il faut bien le
dire dans une forme d'opacité qui en
gêne certains je le comprends très bien
d'ailleurs demain je ferai partie des
quelques députés qui ont l'occasion
d'aller consulter mais dans des
conditions assez rocambolesques et c'est
à dire un peu dans des endroits
sécurisés sans téléphone sans crayon
consulter pendant 50 minutes les
contrats du vaccin curve acte qui au
demeurant a reçu énormément gens
d'argent de l'europe ce qui en soi était
une bonne chose
donc l'europe a été trop lourde dans
cette fonction qui a été de conclure des
contrats à d'ailleurs je note qu'elle
s'est auto saisie de cette mission en
haut lieu et place en lieu et place des
états ce qui n'est pas une forcément une
bonne chose
et effectivement il ya une lourdeur
sachant que certains états s'en sont
affranchis mais que la france ne s'en
affranchit a faim et par ailleurs je
voudrais noter pour rebondir sur ce que
veut dire monsieur alexandre que à
toutes les étapes de la responsabilité
il y a un vrai problème qui est augmente
le scepticisme à savoir qu' il a été dit
de nombreuses fois que les laboratoires
se défausser de toute responsabilité par
avance non pas de la fabrication elle
même là ils sont responsables mais des
aléas secondaire
des effets qu'on ne connaîtrait pas
encore mais je dois dire aussi que l'on
ne peut pas non plus demander un
consentement éclairé à des personnes
quand on ne peut les éclairer sur rien
du tout puisque on ne connaît pas les
effets à moyen et long terme on connaît
bien et c'est là c'est assez rassurant
on connaît bien les effets à court terme
le vaccin moderna a été comment
dirais-je testé sur l'homme depuis le 16
mars 2020 cd trouve ça quand même plus
d'un an les travaux sur la rn messager
et sur les coronavirus sont très anciens
donc la rapidité de la rn message et ne
doit pas étonner c'est que ce n'est pas
la méthode qui va être celui de sanofi
qui ne viendra qu'en fin d'année
mais pour autant il va bien falloir que
l'on créé le concept de responsabilité
sanitaires des états ça avait été
discutée à propos de madame bachelot en
il faut qu'on remette ça sur la table il
faudra bien s'il ya eu des retards des
manquements ou des négligences que celle
ci soit retenue parce que la perte de
chance à la limite sur la maladie et on
pense quand même aux 66 mille personnes
décédées mais aussi sur sept vies
gâchées de toutes les générations depuis
un an mais bon on peut dire au moins
depuis six mois puisque nous avons quand
même eu les exemples des pays du sud est
asiatique de l'australie qui nous ont
montré la voie nous n'avons pas voulu
voir ces exemples est véritablement ça
nous pose et monsieur vers on continue
dans une position tout à fait crispé de
ne pas voir qu autour de lui
la ville voudrait continuer alors que
lui prend des sites il prend des
décisions qui sont toutes trop rapide on
ne laisse pas du temps au temps pour
voir si telle ou telle mesure fonctionne
à maintenant on nous dit passer de 20h05
dans les bouches du rhône nous y somme
de 20 heures à 18 heures mais on n'a pas
laissé le temps au 20h de prouver que
c'était une bonne solution et du coup on
va arriver dans le confinement
généralisée très bêtement
voilà et il faut pouvoir par ailleurs
permettre à tous ceux qui veulent se
faire vacciner de le faire que les
autres veille attendre et bien ils
attendent de toute façon est repassé de
vaccins on a un tout petit peu de temps
mais pas plus que ça il faut que le
virus
arrête de
circulez sachant que les variants
arrivée bouscule toutes les donnes où je
vais justement joëlle mélin leur
confinement le variant qui sont
directement liés au sujet de l'école on
en a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui
puisqu'on a appris par santé publique
france que la possibilité avait bondi la
première semaine de janvier hier jusqu'à
10 % chez les 10-19 ans d'entrain
évidemment des interrogations et des
préoccupations sur la fermeture des
classes et des cantines mise en cause
par certains l'europe
vous le voyez sur cet écran est scindé
sur cette question regard des sept pays
qui maintiennent les écoles ouvertes la
france la belgique l'espagne le portugal
et la suisse la suisse d'ailleurs où une
étude a clairement montré que la
fermeture des classes avaient un impact
efficace sur la circulation du kobe 19
en france mini de l'éducation lui a
expliqué que la fermeture des classes et
ben c'était vraiment le tout dernier
recours mais est-ce qu'on doit au moins
fermé les cantines pour renforcer la
sécurité sanitaire dans dans les
établissements c'est la question que
beaucoup se posent
laurent alexandre c'est une question
difficile par rapport à d'autres pays
que vous avez indiqué qu'ils ont fermé
les écoles la france est dans une
situation différente
en france le niveau des enfants a
beaucoup baissé ces dernières années les
inégalités territoriales sont plus forte
en france que dans les autres pays il y
a des tas d'enfants qui sont en
décrochage
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation
francs dina vous il ya une assez bonne
homogénéité du niveau scolaire et les
derniers classements il s'agit de pizza
ou des classements science montre que le
niveau des jeunes français s'effondre en
mathématiques et en sciences le niveau
des jeunes français est en train de
s'effondrer dans une société très
complexe où les pays d'asie gagne sans
arrêt des parts de marché si nous avons
des gamins culte en 2040 ils sont
parfaits de prouver un boulot de qualité
donc effectivement nous sommes face à un
dilemme
l'école peut participer à la diffusion
des variants mais dans un pays la france
où le niveau scolaire des gamins s'est
effondrée depuis 30 ans fermer les
écoles pose un énorme problème de
justice sociale et puis un problème
politique vous
maginez avant même le confinement le
niveau des gamins s'est effondré en
france que va-t-il se passer si on a un
confinement strict et une fermeture des
écoles donc oui c'est un choix cornélien
est très très difficile
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation des
autres pays nous avons un grave problème
scolaire et je le répète l'effondrement
du niveau de nos gamins en france et 1
est un énorme problème qui qui rend
difficile la fermeture des écoles
alors vous me faites pas le jour enfin
vous n'évoquez pas plutôt pardonnez-moi
les problèmes psychologiques qu'ils sont
nombreux entre les pédiatres le relève
joëlle mélin
pour le coup vous suivez la ligne du
ministre de l'éducation qui d'ailleurs
apparemment et en étant division avec
certains de ses collègues du
gouvernement de se dire voilà coûte que
coûte
on laisse les écoles ouvertes et ça sera
vraiment le le tout dernier recours avec
ce débat notamment à je le disais tout à
l'heure sur sur les cantines qui sont
pointés du doigt vous comprenez qu'on
qu'on laisse l'école en tout cas ouverte
pour le moment pour les mêmes raisons
que monsieur à l'écran alexandre je peux
comprendre que c'est un vrai problème
que de les refermer
mais c'est l'occasion pour moi de
soulever une interrogation que je
n'arrive d'ailleurs pas encore une fois
à comment dirais-je a levé je pense
qu'il y a des voies de contamination que
l'on n'a pas encore je recherchais en
particulier la salive et la chaîne des
objets de table partiellement les verts
et les fourchettes qui sont directement
porter à la bouche ne sont peut-être pas
suffisamment surveillé
j'en veux pour preuve aussi c'est que
j'ai moi monsieur monsieur alexandre a
fait son un effort en faisant les 45
pages du et comment dirais-je du
consentement éclairé moi j'ai fait celle
des quarante et une page de l'umih vous
savez la grande le grand syndicat de
l'hôtellerie il n'ya strictement rives
sur le circuit découvert et des verts en
salle pour l'hôtellerie et encore moins
pour les bars il y a aussi un autre une
autre contamination qui n'est pas que la
peau des mains ou la peau du visage
quand on s'embrasse ou canto sur touche
le nez ou la bouche c'est la totalité du
corps les études japonaises ont prouvé
que il y avait là ça reste le virus
restait sur la peau 8 à 9 heures et les
japonais qui eux ont une hygiène
corporelle tout à fait surdimensionné
par rapport à nous et bien eux ont très
peu de mort je pense qu'il faut qu'on
regarde aussi qu'il ya peut-être
d'autres voies de contamination que
uniquement les postillons et puis les
mains qui aurait touché la mouche l'on
capté des efforts à faire de ce côté là
peu pour arriver peut-être en sûrs
ans à ne pas fermer nos écoles voilà
après je ne suis pas la mieux placée
pour savoir si on doit les fermer ou pas
ce serait tout à fait dramatique mais
comme dans tous les pans de l'économie
française et tous les pans de société
jose rappeler quand même une chance
c'est que lors des auditions de
septembre une jeune femme le nom
m'échappe à la seconde a dit qu' un
jeune médecin généraliste a dit que et a
bien prouvé que beaucoup beaucoup de nos
concitoyens avait été retrouvé mort chez
eux pas dû qu'au vide uniquement de
solitude et d'avoir entendu à longueur
de journée des informations extrêmement
déprimante voilà donc il est clair qu'il
faut s'en sortir le plus vite possible
j'incite vraiment les pouvoirs publics
et toutes les universités et dieu sait
quel travail à nous fournir au plus tôt
toutes les études exploitables je sais
que beaucoup beaucoup de gens de talent
de travail
je sais que d'autres confrères se
plaignent nous n'arrivons pas à avoir
des études qu'ils soient des études
synthétique nous avons que des tout
petits bouts dernier point aussi il
faudra quand même qu'on s'occupe d'eux
l'origine de ce virus parce que si on en
savait plus sur l'origine peut-être
aurions-nous de meilleurs moyens pour le
combattre un des inspecteurs de l'om s
sont en route vers pékin actuellement en
espérant qu'ils puissent se travailler
dans des conditions de transparence
satisfaisantes merci en tout cas joëlle
mélin députée européenne identité
démocratie ex médecin même si on le
reste à vie n'est-ce pas gériatre
laurent alexandre merci également
essayiste et chirurgiens d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france